>> It's On
Ramazan: I'm Ramazan from Germany, I'm Muslim
and...
Soetendorp: I'm [inaudible] Soetendorp, a
Rabbi from Holland.
Ramazan: Yes, and we want to give the world
a Muslim Jewish peace message.
Soetendorp: Our heart is united, and we think
of the babies in Gaza.
We hope that they will be healed and live.
And the babies in Israel together have a future
of security and friendship.
And we hope that our friendship is just a
small stone towards building that new home
where we all feel comfortable.
Ramazan: And as a Muslim, I want to say to
the Israelis to the Jewish people, I wish
you peace, I wish you security and I wish
you that we could be altogether friends in
the future.
We work on it.
And I think two people have to find a learn
to other people and [inaudible] and then we
are much of people, much of people of peace.
And I believe in peace and freedom.
And I think that Muslims and Jewish are Brothers
and Sisters.
I think they can give together the world much
of things.
We need the peace for us both.
Soetendorp: And you know
Soetendorp: And you know we didn't know each
other forty days ago, and we are Brothers.
I will never go to sleep without thinking
of you, and wake up without knowing that you
are there.
And so to my Brothers and Sisters, Palestinians,
in Gaza and everywhere, my dream is that your
dream fulfilled.
Of peace, security, love, compassion.
And that the tremendous resources of the new
future that are in you will make the Middle
East not to a place of tears, but a place
of hope for all human kind.
Ramazan: So I think my dream is going to be
a reality cuz [pause]
Peace and friendship for you, peace and friendship
is not future, is not dream is reality.
Soetendorp: No
Ramazan: So listen to us and try the same.
Thank you very much.
Soetendorp: Thank You.